une rencontre qui a lieu deux ans après
la visite des manuels macron au château
de meseberg au nord de berlin
le couple franco allemand avait alors
adopté un accord sur la création d'un
budget de la zone euro ce lundi
ils se retrouvent dans un même contexte
de démarche de solidarité entre les pays
de l'ue eux il s'agit de remettre sur
pied les économies européennes
affaibli par la pandémie de coronavirus
emmanuel macron veut partager avec
angela merkel son plan de bataille pour
obtenir un accord de tous les leaders
européens sur le fonds de relance
européen et le futur budget pluri annuel
de l'union européenne au mois de juillet
nous devons envoyer le signal d'une
solidarité européenne est aussi un
message d'efficacité de l'europe au
coeur des discussions
le plan de relance de 750 milliards
d'euros proposée par la commission
européenne
mais les pays dits frugaux l'autriche la
suède le danemark et les pays-bas s'y
opposent
ces derniers se montrent réticents à un
projet d'endettement commun
après anglet la merkel il y a quelques
jours emmanuel macron est monté au front
dès le lendemain il s'est rendu à l'ail
et aux pays-bas pour rencontrer le
premier ministre néerlandais mark rutte
eux d'après l'elysée le président est
revenu avec les ingrédients d'un accord
les dirigeants des pays de l'union
européenne entreront dans le vif des
négociations lors d'un sommet mi juillet